mars 2008 jo de pékin en chine ne
commence que dans cinq mois et pourtant
la tension est déjà à son comble cinq
mois des jo de pékin ayant comme tout
chose à faire et les droits de l'homme
c'est encore violet et les prisonniers
politiques libérés jamais des jeux
olympiques n'avaient autant cristallisé
les débats en cause notamment la censure
des médias mais surtout la situation
politique au tibet qui s'envenime dans
cette région chinoise les tibétains
réclament leur indépendance des
manifestations ont lieu violemment
réprimée par le régime chinois
aujourd'hui si deux tibétains discute un
peu trop fort et plus de 30 secondes
dans la rue ils sont immédiatement
frappé coup emmené en prison face à ces
drames des voix s'élèvent et tentent de
faire pression sur la chine comme
reporters sans frontières le 24 mars
2008 en grèce la flamme olympique est
allumé opération coup de poing pour
l'organisation non gouvernementale
devant un millier d'invités
le responsable chinois des jo de pékin
commence son discours quand soudain un
homme temps de déployer une banderole
boycotter les pays qui piétinent les
droits de l'homme quelques jours plus
tard le 7 avril 2008 nouvelle action de
la part de reporters sans frontières non
sans risque a paris sur la tour eiffel
et la cathédrale notre-dame des
militants déploie cette banderole dessus
le message est clair les anneaux
olympiques sont devenus des menottes
partout dans le monde les mouvements de
contestation continue au népal en inde
ou encore à bruxelles en belgique là-bas
le 8 août 2008 des tibétains veulent
marquer le coup sur ces images des
détenus ensanglanté et autour de leur
cou les anneaux olympiques
pékin qui accueille les jeux sera
impliqué russie le pt 1 qui oppriment
tout un peuple le peuple tibétain et 8
août 2008 toujours les jeux s'ouvrent à
pékin pendant deux semaines la chine
temps de montrer un nouveau visage du
sport rien que du sport mais selon cet
historien des jo il ne faut pas être
dupe la chine veut simplement donner une
image aseptisée de son pays et son but
c'est de diffuser des images de liesse
et de succès dans les médias dans les
journaux par voie d'affichage pour
montrer que le monde entier reconnaît la
légitimité du parti communiste pour
diriger la chine
quatorze ans plus tard en 2022 pékin
s'apprête à accueillir une nouvelle fois
les jeux ceux d'hiver cette fois et
encore une fois la question des droits
de l'homme se retrouve au coeur des
débats
[Musique]